foreign
so yeah this talk is about fine-grained
cryptography and it's probably going to
be a bit all over the place so hopefully
it will be interactive but that's kind
of up to you
I mean I try to keep it relatively light
uh but well maybe I won't succeed
um so there will be a lot of definitions
and like things will be changing all the
time so if you stop paying attention you
can just uh tune in a couple of minutes
later you'll be fine okay so fine grain
cryptography or how to do cryptography
even if cryptography does not exist
so yesterday we
were
some progress I guess in trying to prove
a sort of dream cryptographic dream
serum
right either P equals NP or one-way
functions exist
and right this really gives you a would
give an amazing win-win because right uh
fast like sat right fast set algorithms
would be could be potentially
transformative in society and right
cryptography has already been
transformative
so but unfortunately it as was
highlighted yesterday there are many
sort of known obstacles to to proving
such a theorem and so and then still
like to this day right uh and
pagliazzo's five worlds still remain
separated although maybe this will
change in the very very near future I'm
not sure
um but right right on the just to sort
of go through this again right in the
one hand we have P equals NP
algorithmica I just sort of made these
pictures uh heuristica where you know
you can't solve on the worst case but
you know natural thing natural instances
are easy here natural instances are hard
but cryptography doesn't exist minicrypt
we have one-way functions symmetricy
cryptography all sorts of things
cryptomania which is I guess Loosely
defined to be public key exists and
potentially much more
public key cryptography exists
um and so sort of the one the motivation
for one motivation at least for looking
at fine-grained cryptography or a number
of motivations is maybe we can hope to
circumvent these barriers
uh by like maybe the maybe is there some
way to circumvent these barriers I'm not
I haven't said what fine-grained
cryptography means yet
um and another sort of motivation is
like maybe we want to recover some sort
of Security even if we're in sort of one
of these bad bad worlds uh like
heuristica or algorithmica or Pepsi lab
so can we hope to recover some notion of
security because right without security
or society would collapse basically
um okay so so the the approach we take
in fine-grained cryptography is very
naive or natural I guess depending on
how generous you're being
um so so right what do we do we refine
the adversarial model or write so right
classically classic crypto cryptographic
adversaries uh right they run in
arbitrary polynomial time where you're
not fixing this polynomial ahead of time
and fine-grained cryptography or at
least I guess in the sense of
fine-grained cryptography that's uh I'll
be discussing today uh we're going to
just crop the running time okay so now
potentially right b equals NP it might
be that P equals NP but the stats can
only be solved in N to the 100th time
right which is I guess not very useful
probably but it means that we can still
hope to potentially recover some
meaningful notion of security and in 100
time is
incredibly infeasible for ver like n
equals two right it's already infeasible
so so so so so maybe there's some hope
here and maybe this uh this sort of
classical
dichotomy leaves some room to maneuver
I guess this is the this is the big the
big Point
um and so so
and so sort of yeah bounding the running
time is one notion of considering
fine-grained cryptography and that's
what sort of I'm going to be focusing on
here
but right there's other Notions of
bounding adversaries that you can
consider and have been considered so you
can consider sort of logarithmic space
adversaries other classes within p and
C1 is so sort of very efficient parallel
time adversaries or even ac0
adversaries and as you get lower right
as you get to ac0 maybe you have some
hope of uh doing getting very strong
results unconditional results
in a second
um I should mention sort of two other
models that have become incredibly
important uh I think in the practice of
cryptography
um in recent years and so one is uh sort
of so uh sequential time so here you
have an adversary where you're bounding
the number of sequential so you're
bounding the number of sequential
operations Say by some fixed polynomial
but sort of you can have arbitrary
arbitrary parallelism you're not
bounding the parallelism sort of a
Converse model is sort of your bounded
bounded space so where you're bounding
this sort of space complexity of your
adversary but maybe you give him uh
relatively unbounded time
adversary the good
and more bounded
so okay I'm going to discuss sort of
different regimes so this is like I
guess it's my next a cryptographic
regime is exactly what you're describing
so in the cryptographic regime sort of
uh and the cryptographic regime this is
like right where the honest party is
very weak and he's trying to fight
against this very strong ever say maybe
not classically not quite as strong if
it possible adversary but still much
much stronger than it is
uh what did I want to say right yes uh
but before before we get into the the
reads
um so right so in this talk I'm just
going to focus on end of the sea
adversaries I'm not going to be very
specific about what this means you can
think of it as a circuit of size into
the sea or whatever yeah so maybe that's
the best model
and okay so and maybe some more reasons
so okay so maybe you want to get around
some barriers you want to prove stronger
results I guess or I don't know show
that photography is possible in these
worlds but there are other maybe
motivations even if you believe that you
know one-way functions exist
uh why would you want a weakened
security
um so so one reason is it gives you a
potentially new new sources of
cryptographic Partners
um by considering sort of new problems
that maybe are not even super
polynomially hard but maybe maybe maybe
but maybe robust against say a I don't
know new new attacks
um write the the sources of say post
Quantum hardness are are relatively
fewer and far between
um another reason is maybe you can get
more efficient cryptography cryptography
is expensive particularly public key
cryptography and especially as you get
fancier and fancier it gets more and
more expensive maybe if you consider a
weaker adversarial class and don't worry
so much about super super strong
adversaries you can get something that's
more concretely efficient
and the the sort of and the final reason
I guess that I have on this slide uh is
sometimes it's necessary and sometimes
it's actually what you want and sort of
we'll get to this later on but yeah
yeah okay so first the cryptographic
regime
um right so here
we're going to think about sort of just
sort of scaling down
classical cryptographic Primitives so
here is a sort of very incredibly
informal definition of a fine-grained
one-way function or like what I would
call an N squared hard fine grained
one-way function
sort of I want you to keep in mind I
guess for this talk so right we want a
function that you can compute in sort of
the forward Direction you can compute f
of x and essentially linear time but it
should be hard to invert and say a
quadratic time strictly less than
quadratic type let's say
okay
and and this is sort of the this
formalism that I have here so right what
are we saying exactly so strictly hard
to invert in quadratic time what do we
mean is it's hard to shave off an
arbitrary polynomial Factor this is sort
of the the what we're going to mean by
hard to invert in sub quadratic time and
where is this uh
I guess I'll say in a minute where this
comes from but just as a quick sanity
check so right we relaxed oops we relax
this notion of security
sorry my slides here are not matching my
computer anymore I'm not sure what's
going on uh the sorry just as a quick
sanity check can is there any hope of
like making by this relaxation we get
unconditional security no or probably
not because right this will give you
polynomial bounds on Sat so but right is
it does it is it possible yes because
right a one-way function right we're
just we just have this sort of weaker
guarantee on that we just care about
this weaker guarantee so a one-way
function of course satisfies this
definition
okay
um
you can do complexity leveraging to get
it get it yeah
why is it that sanity check what if it
was possible to do unconditionally that
would be even better
that would be better but I'm just trying
to make sure that it's like uh we're not
dreaming too big I guess right we we did
something very simple to try to get
around these barriers it's not going to
solve all of our problems I guess
um side I'm trying to understand what
the same check is NP is is not in uh
quadratic time
already so I think you mean like end
time
it replace new things yeah I'm sorry
okay yeah yeah
do we have any candidates for this
option which are not just Broadway
functions yeah I'll get to that in a
second thank you
yeah so yeah maybe I'm not I'm not uh
stating this correctly either though
right so you can think of a
parameterized version right where where
like you're not gonna be able to speed
it up
okay
um
all right so so where what is the uh
what is the sort of so I guess where is
this Epsilon coming from so so what is
what is a potential place where you
might hope to mine uh assumptions I
guess to build these Primitives and this
is a fine-grained uh complexity and so
this fine-grain complexity at least my
understanding of it was born out of this
this observation that for many natural
problems brute force or something
essentially close to brute force was
essentially safe the state of the art
okay
Maybe
I don't know Russell or Ryan can say
something
different
I mean in general not necessarily Brute
Force but whatever algorithm we came up
with 50 years ago yeah yeah
okay sure yeah I guess I'm going to talk
about some examples
but it's not
we've been doing it for 50 years old so
not only 50 but not me personally
close
getting closer
so so out of this so uh sort of a theory
was developed this sort of theory of
fine-grained complexity so written in
the theory of say NP completeness the
sort of tool that you're using is
so right what do you want to so this
Theory says like right theorems of the
following form if you can improve the
exact complexity of X where exact means
improved by a arbitrary small poly
Factor then you can improve the exact
complexity of Y
okay and sort of the tool here is this
notion of a fine-grained production
right the production it preserves the
exact complexity of the problems
um right so the analog writes this is
not like a polytime reduction because a
polytime reduction might might might
eat all of sort of the the exact
complexity in it so you have to be very
very careful here
we'll see maybe an example or we will
see an example
and at some point but uh and right and
this theory is sort of LED so as soon as
you have like theories of dependencies
and all of these problems right these
problems where there's been sort of no
algorithmic progress for 50 years led to
sort of conjectures for many natural
natural problems natural like
interesting problems I think that are
important for data science and stuff
like this that's okay maybe not Brute
Force but something relatively simple is
essentially the best thing that you can
do
okay so right back to the previous
question so what uh how what sorts of
things did imply these fine grained
one-way functions
but are not one-way functions and so
right so disclaimer like neither of
these are particularly interesting in
some sense but I think that it's worth
the sort of looking at because they it's
not clear that they imply one-way
function so for example the planted cake
conjecture so this says that if you take
a random sparse graph and you plant a
click of size K somewhere in it it
should be take essentially n to Decay
time right essentially numerating
overall possible clicks to find this
click of size kit
that's true
right sorry about that and then for
example another example is the the
Quezon
K7 problem
so right so Quezon says right if you're
given an integers these think of this as
very large integers and some targets t
such that K of these numbers sum to T
find the sub find this subset that
sensitive
um
okay ah right and both of these problems
think about K as being a constant
the distribution lead I mean if it's the
random program
can you repeat the question also
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so Raul is asking what the graph would
be uh I don't have a good
is this worse because this is average
case so there it doesn't yeah it's like
two yeah
because it's very yeah yeah okay so all
right so there's a lot of this Let's
ignore Let's ignore the top line here is
here is a a injection that works if you
think about for example so you can think
about some notion of the zero cake which
is sort of a combination of click click
and K7 and this this I guess
yeah you said something about maybe this
is not an interesting example right I
wanted to ask how can something like
isn't it interesting by virtue of
employing fine grain one my pleasure how
do you judge interest I'm saying this is
not interesting because this assumption
is already you're assuming it's one way
so
so right this like I'm I'm the
assumption that it's hard to to find but
to find a set but there's some store is
is you're assuming that it's a one-way
function
so in this sense it's not very
interesting like the theorem this
implies to find great Runway function
the proof it's like yeah you already
assumed it but yeah over some
distribution that we haven't subscriber
I guess I haven't specified the
distribution for a pay sum exactly but
you should see
uh uh these integers as being uh
significantly think of them as like
working mod P
that's significantly greater than n to
the k
and then they're just random numbers and
you choose a random subset of size K and
plan to Target
and then the
yeah
this okay
um so right as I said these this these
these at least the second can the second
uh conjecture is not a very interesting
way of getting to a fine-grained one-way
function
um
so but but yeah so one given that this
is sort of a meta complexity uh Workshop
maybe one thing you might try to do is
maybe try to characterize
uh
fine grained one-way functions or even
find worst case of hardness assumptions
that
that implies one of my functions to a
fine-grained one-way functions
so intuitively maybe one you could hope
that something like
a time-bounded comma growth complexity
if it's only weekly hard like if you
only assume it's hard against uh you
know N squared time adversaries maybe
you can hope to get something although I
think that this it's not clear that this
will give a characterization or sort of
say why in a second
uh
and right and the problem I guess
towards sort of cut off the problem with
achieving such a characterization
is that these fine-grained reductions
are are uh very delicate so right
so right they're in a fine grained
reduction we want to say like right if I
can improve the exact complexity of a
problem a then there's reduction that
improves the exact complexity of a
problem B but so let's think about the
specific case where ta equals TB then
you can sort of only make a few calls to
the underlying solver for a right you
can't make you have to make a sub
polynomial number of calls at least in
if you're using it in a black box right
but that's that is oh yeah I mean you
can you can call so actually
reductions which but yeah you can do you
can do incoming small calls yeah exactly
exactly like the entire Google's class
yeah
yeah but some sense in the Crypt in a
cryptographic setting if you're calling
on like different parameter regimes you
need to be careful because you might be
losing the the hardness that you need
the missing but yeah absolutely I'm not
saying I'm just saying this is some sort
of very sure bad intuition and
definitely there are ways around it it's
just how to do it
requires a lot and yeah I yeah in terms
of like getting a characterization okay
this is why in this some of these
characterizations which use exactly that
strip that we call it a smaller inputs
yeah yeah
absolutely but I guess the issue here
and I say something in a second but
right the issue is like it's not clear
how to do like kill for example if you
wanted to use your
right so and there's there's actually
sort of so this is this is this is uh
just a very high level intuition for
sort of one potential issue you could
run into but there's actually sort of
Black Box barriers from uh Christian
uh Charlotte barriers to sorry I'm
showing a sort of at least amplifying
going from average case hardness to fine
grains
uh okay so like uh so as I said there's
some potential problems so one thing for
example you might want to do or maybe
one like so let's look at some sort of
like classical mini style theorems
that you might want so for example one
thing you might want to do is you might
want to wait amplify a week a fine grade
one-way function to a strong fine brain
function
okay so so Paul is like I can Embark
with the suppose that we can I just
promise that you can't invert with the
constant probability and I want to
amplify this to say just maybe just one
over n
right this
sort of intuition from before is right
in some sense you know if you're making
a a black box reduction
uh to to this a prime you're gonna have
to make end calls right this is the I
guess maybe rudich's observation right
there's formal barriers for hardness
amplification and something like if
you're only calling a Prime on random
instances you need to call it at least
10 times even expect it to work once
right
and and so and the the upshot of this is
if this guy is running in say like just
strictly quadratic time and you're
making end calls then all of a sudden if
you compose it with your reduction you
now have something that's running in
cubic time so you're not preserving this
sort of it doesn't these reductions
don't preserve the the fine-grained time
complexity at least so
uh but maybe there's there's better
things
100 versus
but maybe I want to study just like
what's possible
maybe you're right I can invert
everything in as first time and so this
is
she really wants to protects yeah I
think this is the the interesting that's
true yeah
the natural examples where you stuck
could about the partisan if you're not
generalized
for a one-way function so there are sort
of there are fine-grained problems uh
that aren't as parameterized I guess
that it's yeah potentially right so
these the parameters for problems I
showed before like you can just keep
scaling up the parameters and some of
them are some problems maybe you only
have Partners a problem that's not
parametrized in the same way I'm not
sure a
I guess I'll say something later I'm
going to talk about proofs of work and
here there's sort of the we don't know
how to get super quadratic but this is
sort of a different machine at least I
don't know how to get super quadratic
Partners without introducing new
assumptions to sort of fill them up
so yeah it's a good question
okay
okay all right so another another
primitive you might consider another
fine grain primitive potentially a more
useful one is a fine-grained
pseudorandom generator so here right we
want a generator that's computable this
is like a cryptographic find grain
it's a random generator if we want a
generator that can be computed in
quasi-linear time but shouldn't be
distinguishable from uniform in some
quadratically
so right can we hope to do prove some
theorem some sort of version of the hill
in this setting
um and here's again sort of a very naive
sort of uh problem here is like any prg
distinguisher is only returning one bit
and in some sense intuitively like it's
a brave to invert the one-way function
you need to recover n Bits this is okay
I'm not saying that this is this is
always the case if this is not a formal
barrier but this is sort of some some
sort of problem here at least if you're
trying to do something generically and
so it seems like some reduction isn't he
going to need to make end calls right
this has been there are formalizations
of this the travisan and general and
stuff like this so there are
formulations of like sort of barriers
here and right and this
the supplies like even if like you want
to just like yeah you start with a
one-way permutation variant
but yeah so I'm just curious like uh so
do you think such a thing should be
possible and we just need to find the
right to Anchor you think that'll be
like in this setting uh these Notions
might be separated
everything is possible
yeah but uh yeah I'm sure like there's
there's probably a way to to phrase yeah
yeah so you can rule out certain words
yeah yeah it seems it seems possible but
maybe there's
there's a right for every every function
maybe there is a reduction or something
like this yeah
it's like not going by this reduction
out
[Music]
some assumption may be sufficient like
it may be we can give me a one-way
function which can then give me every
yeah
yes
to my next to my neck the next just like
I guess maybe one more a couple more
slides and okay so right this where I
release right for the problem right you
had to to can you had to recover too
many bits but it's potentially possible
one way around at least this barrier
right recovering too many bits is this
right maybe I don't care about all of
the bits or maybe my input the input is
like I only care about sparse input so
there really aren't that many inputs and
I don't need to learn so many bits
and then maybe I only need to recall run
in something you know uh that's that's
sub polynomial in fact
okay so where
it and so what so where are we going to
get uh fine grains krg or one one way to
get one is from this uh K7 function so
right this is just sort of rewriting the
the Json uh this is like the one-way
function that you get from this targeted
hey son it's all right you get a random
uh think about like it's being random
right random a random X and right to
Output the the numbers a and the the
inner product
uh I guess right I should have sold on
let me back up right this notation I
guess what I mean k s k n these are like
a k sparse vectors of length n so they
only have a ones
so right when I take this inner product
mod P I'm just this is just I'm just
rewriting summing up okay of these
numbers
so this is just the function and so this
is something we showed with gal Arnold
Alon Rosen and Prashant
yeah
you don't know X you don't answer that
you don't if you can't put X it wouldn't
be so this is sort of like this is the
sort of one way this is why it's one way
correct so to make a stretching you need
to keep it to be much larger
because
if you want to be in this sparse regime
so right there's there's uh right so in
particular right the P I guess yeah I
guess I did that's right he is much
larger than okay than right in this case
right if I sample if I see something of
the form a with the uniformly random
element from uh FP uh right there's not
going to be any solution of size k
inside
but if you assume a lot of people go
away maybe it becomes simpler yeah
so increase
and yeah yeah so right you're saying
you're saying if I want to compose like
in a generic thing yeah this is yeah
this is potentially problematic
uh
right so so what is the theorem the
theorem says that assuming it's assuming
this function is fine grained one way
then it's a fine-grained ERG or in other
words there's a search to decision
reduction for this planted problem right
if I can distinguish the planted
distribution over here
yes maybe I should be using that okay
distinguishes planted distribution
uh from sort of the sort of unplanted
case where it's just a random thing then
I can recover the planted Target
in a fine grade
so how what is the starting point in
which is the bar reduction I should
mention Prashant is a different way of
doing this with his students but I'm
going to show you uh the way that that
I'm familiar with at least so the
starting point is is this classic paper
from apocalypse and Lauren they showed
us to search decision reduction for
subset sum and they're sort of at least
my idea of their sort of critical
observation so like what they wanted to
do is they want to reduce to the gold
rate level predicate and basically if
you just look at these things they look
very similar it's right the subset sum
function is Computing sort of this inner
product where this so let's think about
subsets on that case then so this is
just a zero one vector now instead of a
k sparse vector
it's just Computing this inner product
right this right and right over here
you're Computing an inner product but Z
I guess is also right uh
zero one valued and this is mod 2 and
this is monthly but it's like right it's
almost there
and so what did they do to exploit this
so right what they did is they showed
that if you could distinguish plant it
from random
then you could predict this gold rate
level
the product
okay so right we want to build a
predictor given a distinguisher so what
do the right to the predictor is given Z
this is what you're going to like you're
trying to predict the mineral product of
X which you don't know with Z one to two
the
and you're given the output of this
one-way function
okay
so right right you write this output of
the one by function so I sort of
highlighted in green sort of what are
the sort of uh numbers that are in that
that are in the Target
what did they do so do you have Z they
just sampled a random Alpha from your
field
and multiply it hit Z with it
and then so some sum up the result that
you get
so right you get this new Vector I guess
X prime or something and the question is
what you do with the target
right we need to Output the new Target
and what did they do well
they just sort of uh so right what
should the target be if we wanted it to
stay planted so right all we know that
the target rate is just for some of
these things so right please so this
element for example A2 right will still
appear in this target this like if we
think about sort of the new Target a new
hypothetical Target right this element
didn't get an alpha
this one did get an alpha all you need
to do is count the number of Alphas in
the intersection of where Z and X where
both of them have ones how many both
have ones what was their observation is
you just guessed this right it's a
number between one and N you guessed it
with pretty high probability
and right and if you guess this if you
guessed it correctly
then then I add an M Copy it's like the
number of the intersection copies of
alpha to the Target then this is exactly
identically distributed to a planted
instance
and if I guess it's incorrectly then
I've multiplied right it's Alpha which
is just a random thing by a non-zero
number this is just re-randomizes this
completely it's completely independent
of whatever you've started with
so it's right exactly the random case
so now we can just use our distinguisher
to check sort of approximately which
case are we in and if we think we're in
the right case we uh we just output the
parity of M which is going to be the
inner product right assuming we guess
frankly this is just the inner product
mod too and otherwise we output right
it's independent so it doesn't really
matter
what is the loss so if their loss the
loss is going to be 1 over n because
it's just basically the probability that
you guessed correctly here in the case
as far as case the loss is just one over
K because these are just subsets of size
K so you only need to get the number
between one and the intersection is at
most okay
so
so we're sort of halfway there okay so
right we're following the pattern so
right to so we have a fine business
everything I just said to you it's fine
grain this is fine the problem is so now
once we have this build right 11
predictor we want to use it to recover X
okay let's go to write 11 which is fine
but the problem is total direct 11 has
at least an overhead in expectation
or more if you want to do it exactly
so what do we show is sort of this
simple Lemma
that if we only care about recovering K
sparse vectors
then there exists sort of this new
predicate which is going to be induced
there is some metrics which you can find
efficiently or sample randomly to do if
you care about parameters
a w
uh
such that right if I can predict this
this new predicate induced by uh
okay good if I can produce the right um
this new predicate is very similar to
the right it's just a linear function
again but instead of like a random Z
we're going to sample a short random R
hit W with it to get the Z and get yes
so there's like a whole
um mini area in like signals processing
about sparse buildrike 11th theorems and
I forget what they call it like
of course well
um this particular for like the you know
they think of it Fourier transform okay
it still Falls forward
I think Sparks recovery is a big
umbrella so yeah big umbrella but it's
like compressed sensing
the sensing is over the rails right but
there is a notion of like sparse Walsh
Hatter Mark transforms I'm not sure they
give you exactly what we want here I'm
not sure this is list decoding right
yeah yeah yeah I'm not sure they have
the realistic on it this is exactly the
issue
but it's potentially possible that we're
Reinventing we own this in other
communities
anyways but the main point is that this
is possible and potentially interesting
and so uh right so what do you get right
you can recover this first X at least
right if I only care about expected
running time then it's going to be
quasi-linear in okay
it's very fast
so the the main problems is uh you still
have like Epsilon Square dependence
right so if you're running like K
squared or k cubes time then you can
yeah you're gonna have an Epsilon
somewhere I guess yeah so either you
either you're preserving the the one
over Epsilon I mean you're not going to
be able to to improve the hardness
basically so either you need to pay for
like a
right one over Epsilon squares in your
running time
or you need to pay for it somewhere
actually how do you choose w
ow the key point though is that the
right the previous step doesn't
introduce a big Epsilon right it's just
a one over K loss so whatever if you
started with a pretty good Epsilon then
it's not too much worse what is it sorry
how do you choose
choose w we took a
something from yeah this compressed
sensing literature
so this is
commentatorial compressed sensing or for
all sparse recovery you can so the the
the thing that works and so you have to
be careful for what can work smart too
uh but like sort of the simplest thing
that I could at least understand was
there's like a simple thing if you use
like an unbalanced uh bipartite expander
and that you can construct this yeah
it's like bit masking technique where
you just output the sort of index
okay all right so what is the high level
idea there's nothing complicated there's
nothing actually very complicated going
on so right what are we doing exactly
what I guess Russell is saying right
we're taking something from this
compressed sensing literature that's
tailored to this finite field setting
compressing X to be essentially as short
as possible once we're in this small
Dimension then we have to we have time
we can actually run gold rate level
because it's running in the dimension
polynomial of say in the dimension or in
the way I stated the expected time in
linear in the dimension and then right
and then this is a compressed sentence
scheme which emits uh like very fast
reconstruction
so that's where this is coming from so
what is
you should think of as a concept yeah I
know this doesn't really make sense to
put K but right yeah
it's there's this poly logarithmic
factors and
and one of our Epsilon I guess
okay and the the point being is like
this like the sparse gold rate 11
wouldn't be very hard the the important
thing is like we needed this thing to be
a linear predicate this was really
important for the the previous reduction
and
I guess I'm already out of time I'm not
going to get to the second point but
right so so right in the reduction you
should think of these Z's is chosen by
choosing a random short R and hitting
this Matrix
so uh fine grained
so that's that sort of wraps that up so
find range public key cryptography so in
this this you can imagine sort of uh
this is sort of then yeah
Maybe in some sense one with something
it's not the right abstraction for
finding right because yeah the input is
loud so in no way you can constantly but
that's true that's true
thinking about
so we're finding public key cartography
so here is I guess the definition of
fine-grained key agreements you have
Alice and Bob they're interacting I
guess you want I'm not doing it right
that you want them to be running in I
guess again quasi-linear time but you
want them to be
uh
uh the the keys that they produce to be
secret relative to eat who's running in
say enter the seat yeah
so there's a we have a lot of sort of
results here so uh right Merkel puzzles
like this classical notion from the 70s
this is a fine-grained uh key agreement
with n square
right Yuval and others show that you can
make it worth work with just the
exponentially secure one-way function
instead of a random Oracle
um in a very nice paper from
real Levine Lincoln and vesaviska Will
Williams Williams they showed how to use
to sort of adapt Merkel puzzles instead
of relying on exponentially secure
one-way functions to rely on planted
sort of average case hardness
um either the zero weight K click
problem or the case on the problem
I'm going to say what zero wave cake is
um and they showed uh right did right I
guess like you have some you have some
sort of non-trivial advantage that
approaches 1.5 it's K growth
um so from what I just showed you okay
some sort of we know from sort of a
classic or not so classical but
lubachevsky and others right to given
subsets some you can show some from
subset some you can build public key
cryptography you can emulate regev
encryption uh in a very very spot in a
very very sparse regime
uh and so if you apply what you just saw
you'll get a public key crypto system uh
uh for K over two
um and so this is a recent work of
Prashant and his student uh
schwartzbach and they showed using
assuming kxr and LPN you can also get a
fine grain of the key crypto system yeah
so uh good yes how do you pick k
how do you pick K yes if you're a
practitioner I guess you probably don't
use these games
um but it's because what you're assuming
I guess in some sense
okay to be large enough yeah it is the
largest okay that's reasonable
foreign
example yeah although these are the
painted versions right all of these are
planted versions yeah or like that like
or the sparse yeah
yeah the notion of security also kind of
because we have the security
so here I guess I'm thinking of the
security parameter as n yeah and all of
this does this make sense I mean yeah
maybe you want to tune okay and N but
yeah yeah you need to be right it's like
a mismatch
so are there any Primitives we either
can't get or know we can't get generally
but we can talk about it yes so okay so
there's you can build other Notions
Beyond this and fine-grained crypto and
there's sort of I wanted to briefly
touch on so some other complexity regime
you have an honest party it's much
stronger than the adversary
uh there's sort of some examples so I
guess in derandomization sort of one
example where this occurs but there's
examples first when for security reasons
you want you're sort of forced into this
situation
and maybe you would want to do better
but but you can't in some sense in
particular when you don't have like
secret information and maybe you're
trying to protect the key or something
like this there's sort of no hope yeah
but uh but yeah back to your point
there's other sort of something that's
become particularly uh useful recently
and I guess we already saw an example in
this conference is sometimes we want
crypto that's not too hard to break so
this is sort of the very different so
this is sort of the mixed regime we want
by it's a week
on this very weak honest part is maybe
hiding behind the strong honest party in
a slight maybe all nearly a strong
adversary they want to protect against
so I don't I want to talk about the
defined moderately hard one way
functions but right an example of this
is a proof of work right or a
cryptographic puzzle is something we saw
on Monday and which is sort of a proof
of work without like a non-emergency
number
so in this case right we want rewrite we
want we want the proverb to like be
somewhat efficient we and we want to Bow
but we don't want depending what like
achieving for her to be able to be Maxi
more efficient and still convinced to
verify and this is sort of very very
difficulty
um so yeah and these sorts of things
I'll just say is uh right these sorts of
things you can build from sort of worst
case conjectures and fine grain capacity
uh but critically I guess so back to
something involved as sort of like
Canadian
open question particularly here is
without assuming photography at least I
don't know how to get
approval
that like to get hardness for Proverbs
that are running in say cubic time and
it verifies it's running
so if you want this sort of so right we
can get quadratic Gap so right it's
quadratically hard for the program and
verifier and if with interaction you can
do better but if you want it to be
non-interactive if we really want to
just send the proof and be done which is
like in most sort of applications this
is what you want I don't know how to to
get to know this but potentially there's
some efficient batch verification that
the links get to qubit or something I
don't know
is
is there something that even if I
believe in crypto yet but you would be
able to get in this particular sense
because maybe it's impossible to get a
separation that is non-polynomial versus
polynomials
so can you get here
one example would be Merkel puzzles
so uh
so if you have like a very random
linear time function
then you could use the Merkel key
exchange to do key agreement
with N squared security but you can't do
better than that I think it was saying
if we forget about assumptions
it's usually when we say that something
is impossible to get do it because of me
because of what type of statement still
applying to get usually we mean that
it's impossible to show super
polynomials
yeah now we're all satisfy you so some
something more cryptographic flavors
you're saying
station safe what a wonderful
manifestation is
moment
uh that is a great question I don't have
to answer also talks like also the
other questions
it seems unlikely because you can sort
of Leverage at least specifically for
example yeah yeah
what was the murmurray can you get Black
Box obfuscation the question but what
was the answer no no no
it seems like
it seems like the counter example sure
okay I think we should yeah